okay you're in a lot of trouble  what do you want from me come on sit  down  our timeline is in chaos and you need  the goddess mischief to help you  no key is unpredictable  i know what i am good  bad  [Music]  bit of both original series streaming  wednesday june 9th  only on disney plus  welcome to the time variants authority  i miss minutes and it's my job to catch  you up before you stand trial  for your crimes so settle in now  hang on just a minute  and we'll get you in front of a judge in  no time  [Music]  who actually believes this crasser i'm  going to see your ticket no  [Music]  thanks for visiting the tva don't  hesitate to let us know how we're doing  what do you want from me you put  our timeline in chaos  i want you to help us fix it what could  possibly go  wrong trusting loki is not a good idea  do i get a weapon gear up ah don't those  absolutely not  original series streaming wednesday june  9th only on disney plus  you